we have new information tonight about
the infamous Trump Tower meeting between
the president's son Donald Trump jr. and
some of his father's campaign ads as
well as a Russian lawyer who supposedly
had damaging information about Hillary
Clinton or that was thought of at the
time correspondent Peter Doocy
is on Capitol Hill tonight with the
latest Donald Trump jr. said he kept his
dad in the dark in June 2016 when
Russians came calling with potential
dirt on opponent Hillary Clinton
congressional investigators asked did he
say why wasn't I told about this meeting
no he didn't did you find that odd no
because he wasn't aware of it the
meeting almost didn't happen according
to the music promoter with Russian
clients who set it up Rob Goldstone told
Congress I believed it was a bad idea
and that we shouldn't do it and I gave
the reason for that being that I am a
music publicist politics I knew nothing
about once the meeting started things
unfolded like this according to Ikea
valid say a US citizen of Georgian
descent who works for a group run by a
Russian oligarch mr. Trump asked if they
got anything on Hillary and to which mr.
Ahmed Sheen responded why don't you do
your own research on her we gave you the
idea but ranaghat machine a Russian
lobbyist was asked by investigators was
there any discussion of anything that
might reasonably be considered collusion
between the Trump campaign and the
Russian government not to weigh I
understand it no Trump jr. told Congress
that the meeting was instead primarily
focused on Russian adoptions today Trump
jr. said the public can now see that for
over five hours I answered every
question asked and was candid and
forthright with the committee the
Democratic lawmakers not so sure I have
no confidence
so the top Republican on the Judiciary
Committee may bring Trump jr. back to
testify again things I'll take it under
advisement
this morning Obama era Intel officials
briefed a bipartisan group of senators
about how they came to the conclusion
that Russians mettle to help Trump in an
intelligence community assessment or ICA
which reportedly relied on the infamous
unverified dirty dossier and in a break
with House Republicans Republican
Chairman Richard Burr now says quote we
see no reason to dispute the conclusions
today's top with the Obama era spy
chiefs according to one Democrat in
attendance focus less on Trump campaign
collusion and more on Russians using
Facebook and Twitter to interfere we
never had social media to this extent in
any other election before former CIA
director John Brennan and former
national security adviser James clapper
were not chatty leaving their
closed-door meeting we can tell us about
what he told these days
so the last generation of spy Chiefs was
characteristically tight-lipped as the
next generation got a step closer to the
director's office at Langley
Gina Haspel was easily confirmed today
by the Intel committee next stop a full
Senate confirmation vote it could be as
early as tomorrow
Bret Peter Doocy live on the hill Peter
thank you